hi guys I'm Craig I'm Morgan Morgan and
I shot a couple videos and the mic was
[ __ ] up the whole time so you're going
to miss out on a couple of videos with
us
and we're going to continue the journey
anyway hey let me reintroduce you Morgan
Han you can follow her on Instagram when
life hands you Morgan and she's also the
co-host of the show on YouTube how to's
with Morgan and Ashley with how to with
these hot blondes or have personalities
pinky out so you know the best of both
worlds there and you could follow on how
to you on take a ride as well that's
number two how to you get it the chaco
terrified five deserving videos taken
from the Deep Web I'm scared a little
bit like disturbing or scary let's find
out I'm okay it's okay I need to be able
to sleep tonight
who needs sleep Monroe Bowie
[Laughter]
number five sad Satan Oh No when they
say deep web is not for the
faint-hearted
it's no joke sad Satan is a weird and
creepy game that lately appeared on our
regular everyday internet and to
nobody's surprise deep web is behind
this - apparently the uncensored version
of the game was replete with terrifying
and puke worthy visuals of gore and
brutal child porn throughout this video
itself is like really adding to its
creepy touch it's mostly shot in the
dark
complete with sounds of someone
approaching terrified screams and such
unfathomable noises number four a blank
room suit this video features a
shirtless young man in an empty room
having soup it looks like he is forced
to suddenly there are two faceless
people donned in a weird costume next to
him he appears to be sobbing indicating
that he is a hostage
the figures continue to pat him on his
back tauntingly and seem to relish in
his desperation one theory about this
video is that it is a snuff clip and
that the soup is probably human remains
or waste
apparently these costumes were stolen
from its owner and the makers of this
video sent from this video after a
couple of days
he remains mystery whether this is real
or just a frame at least comforting I
don't know what happened I thought my
brother and I treat yeah come on the
channel number three now hamburger lady
hammers dream amazing realistic short
film and features some hidden messages
she's lying there the hamburger lady she
is dying she's burned from the waist up
on her arm her ear is burned along with
distressing piercing video in black and
white perhaps it's a clever attempt by
the person behind it to make it look
even more ominous it's difficult to make
out any real sense from this clip it
could be a hilarious joke or it could be
something that really happened in that
case who could the hamburger lady be for
the hilarious
oh man what is a hammer girly I want to
have her I'm serious
[Music]
number two crush porn what okay there is
no other word to describe this video
people pay the woman in the video to
dress in seductive outfits and crush
small animals to death with their height
they usually choose shut-ins or puppies
for this apparently this turns some
people on right the viewers also have
the option to pay extra up to 400 u.s.
dollars to request a particular animal
or outfit what well now we cannot argue
when they say humans are the cruelest
species on earth
number one abducted and imprisoned
this is particularly scary as this is
something that can happen to anyone
they say the lady in the video was
recruited as a full-time maid but it
turned out that the employer wanted her
for horribly sinister reasons
some also believe that he could be the
owner of Deep Web he literally
imprisoned and enslaved her with little
food or water with a webcam monitoring
her movements all the time
he wanted to see how long it would take
to break her defenses to perform
atrocious act on her she keeps pleading
for help panicking at the lack of food
and water but to no avail this is more
likely to be a real video as it's
impossible to fake this desperation as
she screams for help hoping to get at
least one of the attackers to take pity
on her the video ends with something or
someone attacking her for this day
nobody knows what happened to her
or if she survived the ordeal hey
there's a dog having sex with a woman in
this video is there gazing quickly I
walk in the light oh my soul can I help
man Wow
I was uh I need a drink I've heard of
sad Satan hurts a crazy crazy game that
was kind of scary the first one scared
me a lot this will creep me out hearts
the one with the guy possibly eating
human remains I mean that's a big theory
there's not a levitating the video
actually alludes to that no other than
ramen yeah
just sad irregular my offer isn't really
just looks like ramen and I was because
I want a clam chowder guys did you Roman
okay okay what the hell were those
costume
I don't know we're too comforting but
that was what made it little is to
create obviously held hostage is he
we don't know if it's fake or real I'm
gonna go real I'm gonna say medium I
don't know somewhere between fake and
real real hurt oh there you go I would
love to have those costumes oh we can
make that I think we can make that I
feel like that's such a kinky sexy
outfit Halloween oh my god on college so
we should we should go ahead get ready
tell me about it okay the hamburger lady
and no one knows who she is she's making
a hamburger and maybe that's one half of
her body got burn and her ears and her
eyelashes or whatever
maybe it's the story of Wendy from
Wendy's she's an emotional flame I say
lost Wendy her father
big work thanks Frank you what is me
hopefully it's like I know it tomorrow
it was like like traumatic and intense
and very like a lot of layers there yeah
Moltres relationship is like your mother
and then you're always like you're
finding you're not your uh your dad yeah
your cold-smoked whitcomb attic and and
the hammer der lady has its mulch cool
it's not like torture Oh surprises
around this one is Wow thank God for the
hammer early yeah I just learned a new
word thanks there girlie I would assume
a murder lady would you know well
believe me I would like to see her I
would have that wasn't even an ago like
him what do you think the hammer der
lady is I think he's a woman a woman
will mate why they call her the
hamburger lady she never went anywhere
with
hamburger is that why maybe that's what
not that's why I'm guess I thought maybe
she's making a hamburger that would be
corset or made-up hamburger ooh that
would be even more interesting but they
killed her why would you kill the hammer
girl and there's no end in sight from
her though I said she didn't know hope
you may be sad and kind of creep I've no
idea what's going on not knowing and not
knowing that was what makes it creepy
yeah really don't know what she looks
like
brilliant and the way they edited it too
was like random images of like sad [ __ ]
going on now the crush porn I've never
heard of crush porn you know I have
cat-like eyes I know
people would just kill them and crush
that is my wife and people pay money and
these animals that you want like a
lizard I would be all in luck yeah I
don't what can kill a snake yeah we're
not in a sexual way you more of like
that one must make the roadway yeah
exactly yeah but he had a little can't
you know we're a papi it's little thing
how could they do that
this is humans I can stick right but I
can't oh my god that made me so
uncomfortable even show footage of it I
just know it I thought they were oh no I
would have I would have turned away to
get that with me yeah no I can deal
oh man that broke my heart at least
though I'm struggling I know where I
could you know how I can make money off
my cat yeah but they're fully grown so I
don't know what it is I think it was
like hey even puppies you crushed your
dreams crushed my cash your backup plan
Oh
kidnapping stuff I hear of a copycat
specifically LM too real I think it
would be such a funny prank to do this
to you Konami
like kidnap you hold you hostage for a
few days and just have recorded two very
addictive something dinner will do that
and I was the cry you cry why cry I
would take a minute then I would
formulate a plan
100% I've seen too many episodes been I
I would pull I would pull I'm full of
hardcore like ninja move and I would I
would find escape you find a way with a
paper I'd like weed that I have that in
me maybe you do I'd like to believe that
I have only I would just have it be like
yeah I would have really want you to
believe this is the end of your life and
I want to get it all on camera that come
on oh come on oh are you fine now in the
book very less funny yeah you won't find
a fine time to be hungry you're probably
on a headache
but you wouldn't be me then give me sue
this but part of the funny is that
you're suffering
I mean maybe like in and out like
appointment today
I don't know once a day I might be
enough to hold you over here yeah be
like a little hungry it'll be fine when
we come on like how we got you now may
we find for me how to do it either by
Norrington I will escape edition stars
this is dark I know if I disappear you
know where I can find me I'm in Greg's
bathroom find me but don't cuz I could
probably save myself at the end of the
day let's be really do something I can
save myself I think you can do I believe
in the palace Solomon I wasn't yeah
there's a feminist conversation for
having yourselves guys yeah cuz a man
could get out of that situation easily
yes a napping a woman is a challenge you
know women prevail a man would come like
a little [ __ ]
we are more sensitive than we let on you
are you panic - no one talks about it
we're a little bad boys on the inside I
respect you for your strength thank you
because if you did that prank of me oh
boy yeah not be cool never forgive you
would never find it funny I was what
make you think I would forgive you look
I'm nice that I'm hard enough IRA women
produce super unforgiving hardcore you
back with me and does that's it I'll cut
you out 100 percent block you on
Instagram Facebook I'll never talk to
you again never least if I say I'm not
going to talk to you not no hard luck
peep I'm sorry that this hypothetical
conversation and the peak provoking you
so much shouldn't anger
I get angry first more than get some in
anger than in sadness is a very famous
getting a spurt guys if something
happens you get masters yeah more done
yeah
then we later laters yeah if you can
manage it I can see where you have a how
to you channel how to handle your
emotions whatever I may have mentally
ill react I can't see that at all hey
guys subscribe to Tara 5 which kind of
the real reject Mauryan pan on how to
use a Morgan and actually she's the
blonde one of the group and also cheese
when life hands you Morgan my Instagram
and also how to blonde make a right on
Instagram and you can go there to the
description box and follow her every
there mainly in the channel though I
just followed her Instagram
I don't know how provocative her photos
are so I can't tell you it's not
provocative not sexy I mean I don't know
not perfect just naturally and once I
can tell that I mean yeah you're like
naturally sexy but it are like the
photos the image is sexy you know
they're happy
nice I'm not like I don't do that whole
thing that the girls really can't let
change
body body you're like I'm going to take
a photo in the mirror in the bikini and
I'm gonna post an inspirational quote to
go along with this instead of just
saying I know you guys want to sleep
with me and I'll do that yeah I'll do
that
ok no close the salic it's hard out here
for a pimp yeah